avec le confinement et les période de
couvre-feu qui se succèdent presque sans
relâche depuis neuf mois il devient de
plus en plus difficile d'être optimiste
quant au retour des soirées dans les
bars ou les boîtes de nuit l'heure n'est
pas à la rouverture de discothèque
les soirées à l'avenir incertain qui
pousse les plus jeunes a enfin dhr la
loi et organiser des soirées
clandestines
s'il ya plusieurs semaines c'est en
région parisienne à joinville-le-pont
que 300 fêtards s'étaient réunis en
toute illégalité
ce week-end c'est à marseille qu'une
fête a été interrompue par
l'intervention de la police
la nuit dernière à marseille plusieurs
centaines de personnes en train de
danser la plupart sans masse une fête
qui s'est déroulée dans le 14e
arrondissement de la cité phocéenne et
qui avait réuni plus de 500 participants
a strasbourg même scénario avec 100
jeunes qui ont été dispersés max a qu'à
22 portraits des jeunes qui ne
supportent plus de passer à côté de leur
jeunesse de ne plus pouvoir se réunir
rencontrer des gens échanger autrement
que sur les réseaux sociaux un discours
tenu par l'un des organisateurs d'une
fête géante dans le 13ème arrondissement
de paris il ya quelques semaines on a
décidé d'entrer en résistance pour faire
la fête car les jeunes n'ont plus aucun
espace pour exister ensemble ils vivent
dans un manque terrible on essaie de
continuer à leur apporter ça malgré les
risques alors soirées clandestines
comprenez vous la révolte des jeunes
david et sasha deux fêtards sont avec
nous pour nous parler de leurs
motivations
elena temps car en carton et en direct
je tiens à dire voilà que camille
lellouche voilà a été testé bien sûr
d'un amant et moi aussi puisqu'en plus
allez voir que dans la grosse charia dit
jeudi tout le monde sera a été aussi
testé parce que voilà on est là il y à
il ya voilà c'est cannes l'ambiance vous
allez voir ça ce sera pour jeudi pour le
moment j'espère qu'ils ont été testés
également david et sasha deux fêtards
voilà quelques jours des fêtes de fin
d'année eux ils en ont marre ils veulent
faire la fête
est-ce que vous allez à des soirées
clandestines oui ouais à vos ébats et
voué corps et vous êtes 1 2 voilà c'est
très rare d'avoir des témoignages comme
ça un de laon qui disons-le à des
soirées clandestines
est ce que vous n'avez pas peur pour vos
proches sinon franchement weather man
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on a on est face
à une détresse psychologique pour nous
mêmes c'est pour aussi toute la jeunesse
française
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que en jeunes
qui habitent à paris à nous en métropole
il est confiné dans un studio du mètre
carré de 9 m² et toute la journée en
différentiel est passé sur mon
ordinateur talent on est face à un écran
pas de vie sociale et la jeunesse et
vivre la jeunesse et avancer la jeunesse
et c'est la vie aujourd'hui on est dans
un an ni dans une atmosphère de mort il
ya eu les attentats galko vide
on a eu deux confinement là on a eu un
couvre-feu on va on va avoir encore un
congo fort mardi donc c'est très
compliqué à gérer
et je sais que c'est pas bien ce qu'on
fait mais voilà alors vous nicolas
pernikoff ce que vous avez à dire à ces
jeunes qui font défection des signes qui
vont à des fêtes clandestines
non mais vous êtes conscient de ce que
vous faites quoi par rapport aux gens de
votre entourage à vos amis à vos grands
parents vos parents vous voyez plus
personne du coup vous rester enfermé
après un roadshow où on est on est
conscient c'est sûr mais aujourd'hui moi
j'ai 23 ans et je considère que sortir
en soirée c'est ce que je dois faire
ces sociétés à tous je peux pas tout
simplement voilà suivre mes cours en
ligne de 8 heures à 18 heures est juste
resté dans mon appart manger des pâtes
tous elle est la journée ce n'est comme
ça mais c'est un peu égoïste non quand
même nom c'est un peu égoïste mais moi
évidemment quand je vais en soirée j'ai
la boule au ventre
j'ai peur mais je prends la mesure de
quoi vous avez peur de quoi vous avez
peur
évidemment j'ai peur de compte elle les
ennemis proches d'accord mais après je
n'avais pas peur de l'amendé avant tout
ça donc l'amendé de 135 euros elle est
pas du tout dissuasif exactement
donc vous êtes à une bande de potes vous
dites 135 euros sont fous totalement on
peut même les payer pour alan soirée la
demande on s'en tape total c'est ça
hortense à ce qu'ils disent je pense que
les commerçants aujourd'hui on est face
à un jugement ce juste tous
on est face à quelque chose qui est
assez compliquée parce que on va en
soirée donc c'est une parole qui est
difficile à défendre qui est très
difficile à défendre
on a bien plus droit de le dire j'ai à
vous avez du courage de venir ici en
baisse à l'amplifier mais aussi et
surtout vous avez été testé positif
puisque toi tu étais à 3 g et 32 g après
la sortie de mais non c'est très
compliqué c'est oublier de porter cette
parole là et je comprends que pour mes
proches ses beaux-parents escaut parents
ou grands parents le savent
attention le savent l'histoire en faire
attention
le mieux que je puisse mais ils sont
d'accord pour que vous sortez vous dites
sort ça va me faire du bien
bon ils ne disent pas ce sort sort pour
sortir mais ils ont conscience que j'en
ai besoin
et kelly qui est très très énervé alors
vous êtes majeur et vacciné donc vous
faites si je puis dire vous faites ce
que vous voulez moi ce qui me rassure
reste c'est que vous me disiez oui je
pars à ces soirées et après je reste
confus mais mais apparemment c'est pas
le cas parce que si vous allez en soirée
c'est votre propre choix vous êtes
adulte si vous voulez avoir une maladie
est peut-être en mourir c'est votre
problème mais si ensuite vous êtes en
train d'expliquer que vous allez quand
même voir vos grands parents quand même
voir vos parents
là par contre c'est très grave donc
rassurez moi et dites moi que vous
restez chez moi je suis de ce qu'on dit
sur le pont japa gens tapent à l'arrêt
alors je suis entièrement d'accord avec
toi moi je trouve ça hyper inconscient
les jeunes qui vont en soirée qui monte
soir avec des centaines de personnes et
qui a prévu mais avec leurs parents moi
personnellement je vis seul et je te
laisserai pas quelqu'un qui va en soirée
va chez ses parents après peut
potentiellement lait contaminé moi je
parle des situations de détresse
psychologique
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui on parle
de la détresse des commerçants parle de
la détresse économique kommersant
vous vous la détresse psychologique des
jeunes et que ce soit des moins jeunes
eh ben elle est oubliée elle est oubliée
au gouvernement ça va me faire la
rencontre aussi de ce qu'on dit parce
que je pense que ce virus
si on rouvre que ce soit les salles de
théâtre etc je pense qu'il faut protéger
les plus faibles les anciens et
apprendre à vivre avec le virus donc
redémarrer une activité alors oui que ce
soit peut-être la fête que ce soit
peut-être le théâtre mais je pense qu'il
va falloir aussi s'adapter donc moi ça
me choque pas parce que je pense qu'il
va falloir vivre avec et protéger les
plus faibles et avancer avec le virus
alors ouais je vous dis comment vous
faites pour aller à ces soirées
clandestines comment ça se passait ce
que vous prenez des mesures de sécurité
quand même pour éviter la police
c'est que c'est pas du tout non pas
vraiment clairement la police j'essaie
de faire ça dans des zones pas trop à
fréquenter quand même pour pas éveiller
les soupçons d'accord après c'est pas
est ce pas non plus là c'est pas une
grande une grande question qu'on se pose
quand le jour de l'an vous allez faire
une fête sûrement 131 124 apparemment ya
pas de couvre-feu
donc apparemment le convient de le
vendre qu'à défendre ne circule pas je
sais pas mais je voudrais savoir parce
que c'est une fête familiale c'est noël
voisine pour moi mais aussi aux familles
on comprend la famille encore pour les
commerçants parce que là il ya nouvelles
bientôt car il ya eu black friday donc
les commerces sont restés ouverts après
après le après le déconfinement mais ce
qu'on vous prend les jeunes
nous on va sortir le 31 certains vont
sortir le 24 décembre voit la balle et a
vite bien sûr qu'ils qui organise ces
soirées en fait parce que c'est quand
même moi yahia du matériel et la musique
et d'alcool qui est vendu comme comment
ça se passe que pour le coup c'est que
ses grands desseins mais il ya forcément
quelqu'un qui est derrière tout ça
n'assure pas d'accord et jeanne camp nou
ce jour les jeunes afin de mise en
danger vous plaît est ce que vous voulez
vous parler ce soir à la télévision est
ce que vous trouvez vous donner le bon
exemple
franchement non non mais je pense qu'ils
encore une fois je veux revenir sur ce
point là je pense que ça fait dix mois
dis moi que le coc l'insee vient en
france ça on s'est pris de confinement
on a fait des efforts on a pensé à nos
proches on a pensé à aux français on a
pensé à notre entourage
aujourd'hui on n'a plus les forces
clairement et ont dit au gouvernement la
plus forte on n'a plus les forces
psychologiques
olivier ferrand avait mis en place un
numéro d'appel pour les fusions
psychologique
il faut savoir que ce numéro d'appel les
appeler majoritairement par les 18 24
ans est en détresse est énorme alors je
sais pas comment on peut faire c'est pas
comme on peut résoudre le problème
aujourd'hui c'est la solution qu'on a
trouvé on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs comprenez vous la
révolte des jeunes oui à 35%
non à 65% temps